RONALD SMITH: As you know, because we
just got this subject started
last time, I'm going to
talk today about ice
in the climate system.
Let me just review the
types of ice that
we'll be speaking about.
Sea ice, which is
frozen seawater.
Ice sheets, which there's only
two of those existing today in
the modern world.
And that's Greenland
and Antarctica.
We'll talk about those.
Later on, next week, when we
talk about climate change,
I'll describe to you how in
earlier days there were some
other ice sheets on Earth.
But at the moment there's
just those two.
We'll talk about
how they work.
Glaciers, both coming down
from ice sheets and from
mountain glaciers.
Ice shelves, icebergs, and
permanent and seasonal
snowfields.
So we'll be going through
those subjects today.
And I mentioned these items
last time, as well.
There are certain important
physical properties that
you'll need to understand in
order to see--in order to
understand really how ice
behaves on our planet.
And I won't go through
those again today.
I went through them at the
beginning--at the end of the
period last time.
But just review those.
We'll be discussing
those as we go.
So let's start with sea ice.
And what I've shown you here
are some diagrams that
illustrate how sea ice changes
with season in the two
hemispheres.
Now remember, this is
frozen seawater.
So about this time of year, late
October, you begin to get
cold air blowing over the
sea surface in the
high northern latitudes.
So we'll focus on these
two diagrams.
And as the cold air blows over
the ocean surface, it draws
heat out of the ocean,
cools it down.
When you get the temperature
down to about what?
Not zero, but about minus two
Celsius, because the salt
depresses the freezing point by
that much, then you start
to get sea ice forming.
It starts usually in small
little patches of ice called
pancake ice.
I'll show you that
in a minute.
And then as the season
progresses, you freeze the
water in between and
those little pieces
of ice stick together.
And a month or two later, you've
got a more or less
continuous layer of sea ice in
these high latitude regions.
And then during the winter,
it deepens.
In other words, you're drawing
heat out of the bottom and
you're freezing more ocean
water onto the bottom.
So the thickness of the
sea ice increases.
So here we are in September,
which is at the end of the
warming season.
That would be the minimum
in the sea ice.
And yet there is some sea
ice remaining from
the previous year.
Then we begin to build
new sea ice.
And about six months later, this
is typically or at least
was--we'll talk about the fact
that it's changing with time.
But this is typically how far
sea ice extends at the end of
the cooling season.
Then it begins to warm again.
And over the summer, you melt
away a lot of this.
And you end up back towards
the minimum.
So there's a big seasonality
in sea ice.
And this is the way
we understand it.
In March, when you've got
maximum sea ice, you have a
stream of sea ice coming down on
the east side of Greenland.
Most of Baffin Bay is
filled with sea ice.
All of Hudson's Bay and James
Bay is filled with sea ice.
And really, it even comes out a
bit into the North Pacific.
But this area stays generally
free of sea ice.
And you know why that is,
because you remember that
the--part of the Gulf Stream
splits off and moves up into
that region.
So even at the maximum of sea
ice, you still have open water
along the coast of Norway and
even up here in an area that's
called North Cape.
Now, of course, in the southern
hemisphere, the
seasons are reversed.
And so it's in March that you'll
have the minimum of sea
ice, because that's when you're
at the end of the
warming season.
And it pretty much
drops to zero.
In other words, you have a
little bit of permanent sea
ice remaining, but really
very little.
And then six months later, at
the end of the cooling season,
you've grown quite a remarkable
area of sea ice,
by, again, freezing seawater.
Later on I'm going to be showing
you what the ice on
Antarctica is doing.
We'll talk about ice shelves.
But keep that distinct from
what we're seeing here.
This is the frozen seawater,
the sea ice that
I'm referring to.
Any questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: Is it because the Gulf
Stream waters are warmer,
or they're just moving faster?
PROFESSOR: They're warmer.
So even in wintertime, the
temperature of the sea surface
here is about plus three
or plus four Celsius.
And remember, the freezing
point is minus two.
So you're not going to get
freezing of these waters, even
though you get terrific
cold winds coming
off of that sea ice.
I was on an expedition up there
20 years ago, right at
the edge of this sea ice,
looking at how that cold wind
was coming off and trying
to freeze the water.
But there was so much heat
convecting out of the water
that you weren't able to
cause any new sea ice
forming in that area.
So it's the warmth of that Gulf
Stream extension that's
keeping that free of ice.
Yes?
STUDENT: How deep is the ice?
PROFESSOR: I'll talk about that.
But typically, it's from--at
the end of the freezing
season, you can freeze ice
about one meter deep.
But if you mechanically stack
it up, which happens in some
parts, you can get it to be
about the height of this room,
three or four meters high.
So compared to the ocean depth,
it's tiny, just the
thinnest skin.
But in terms of real physical
dimensions, I would say maybe
one meter at the end of the
cooling season, in some cases.
Up to four where the
ice has been
mechanically crushed and stacked.
Now I want you to notice
something.
In the Arctic Ocean, it's
ocean at the North Pole.
And it's confined by
continent surround.
And you typically
fill that up.
And you can't go any further,
of course, because you can't
make any sea ice
over the land.
So if you're going to monitor
this sea ice year by year, the
way it's typically done in the
Northern Hemisphere is to
monitor the minimum sea ice,
which is in September.
Maximum wouldn't make much
sense, because you're not
going to fill that
in with ice.
And you've already taken
it shore to shore
in the Arctic Ocean.
So the way you monitor
interannual variations, or
trends, is to keep track
of the minimum.
On the other hand, in the
Southern Hemisphere, the
minimum is pretty much zero.
It goes--you have a continent
filling the South Pole.
And you're not going to form
any sea ice there.
And the sea ice itself
pretty much goes
back to that shoreline.
So the way we monitor sea ice
in the Southern Hemisphere
typically is by the maximum
sea ice that you grow.
Notice, then, that that means
September is kind of the month
where we monitor sea ice in both
hemispheres, even though
the seasonality is opposite
in the two hemispheres.
So be aware of that.
It's a curious way
that we decide to
monitor these things.
So pancake ice looks
like this.
So when the winter is beginning,
and the cold air is
drawing heat out of the ocean,
for a period of some days or
weeks, you have little chunks
of ice that are from half a
meter to a couple meters
in diameter.
They have rounded edges, because
with the wave action,
they keep bouncing into
each other breaking
off any sharp corners.
And then a few weeks later you
begin to freeze and get a more
continuous ice.
This happens to be continuous
sea ice
with compression ridges.
In other words, when you look at
these features like this or
that, that's an area where the
wind has blown the sea ice
together and it has crumpled
along a line.
And so if you're traveling over
sea ice, as the early
explorers were trying to do,
travel over the sea ice to
reach the North Pole, it's not
like some skating rink where
you can just ski or skate
across the sea ice.
In fact, every few hundred
meters, you end up climbing
over one of these compression
ridges, which makes traveling
there extremely difficult.
You have to pull your sledges or
whatever kind of equipment
you have up over these
ridges and then down.
You get maybe 50 or 100
yards, and then
you're doing it again.
So it's very rough going
when you're trying to
cross the sea ice.
Yes?
STUDENT: How tall do
the ridges get?
PROFESSOR: So the
ridges will get typically only
four or five meters high.
But remember, they've got a
root which you don't see.
But in order to support that
extra weight, they also have a
root that goes down
beneath the ice.
So if you measured it from top
to bottom, it might be 20 or
30 meters, but the part you have
to climb over is just 3
or 4 meters, something
like that.
Yes?
STUDENT: How are they formed?
PROFESSOR: By compression.
So the wind, for example,
blowing over the ice will try
to push it.
But if it comes up against a
shoreline, it can't be pushed
any further.
And so you'll end up just
crumpling that ice and
stacking it up along
these ridges.
Yeah.
Good questions.
So here's another picture
of sea ice.
And I wanted to ask you, first
of all, was this picture taken
in winter or summer
would you guess?
STUDENT: Summer?
PROFESSOR: Why?
It was taken in summer.
How would you know that?
STUDENT: The ice isn't
continuous?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
STUDENT: So the ice
isn't continuous?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's got some melt water
in between here.
But there's even a more obvious
answer than that.
STUDENT: Do they hibernate
in the winter?
PROFESSOR: That's true also.
But there's even a more obvious
answer than that.
STUDENT: The sunlight.
PROFESSOR: It's sunlit.
Exactly.
So you could not take a picture
like that in the
winter time.
It would be pitch dark.
So it is true it is melt ice.
It is true the polar bears
walking around.
But even more obvious is it's
sunlit, so that means in those
latitudes that's got to be
a summertime picture.
Just a trick question for
you this morning.
Seeing if you're awake.
So let's take a look
at what happens.
This is a short movie.
And it'll just show you remember
the date is up here.
And you'll watch that change.
And so we'll just watch
how one season's
sea ice grows here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So it's growing now,
filling out the basin.
Look what's happening
in Hudson's Bay.
Filling in James Bay too.
Still growing a bit up here.
But it's now about as far
as it's going to get.
A little bit of extra growth
there in Baffin Bay.
A little bit more growth,
though, in the current
bringing it down.
[END  VIDEO  PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And then
there we are in March.
So that's kind of
at the maximum.
The movie just takes you from
minimum to maximum last year,
in the year 2010.
Now what will happen after that,
not shown, is that this
will all began to melt back.
And we'll end up back towards
that minimum September
distribution.
Let me play that again, just
so you can-- in case you
missed something.
Every place you look
at you see a little
different story there.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Also, the
zooming in is distracting a
little bit.
The shade of white gives you
something about the thickness
or the continuity
of the sea ice.
If there's gaps, that will show
up as a slightly darker
shade of gray.
[END  VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So Rachel
asked about thickness.
Here's some examples.
The mean, from 1982 to 2000 now
it's difficult to measure
ice thickness.
There are various
ways to do it.
The earliest way was to
take a submarine.
In the late '60s they finally
got nuclear submarines that
could pass under
the ice sheet.
And then with an up-looking
sonar you could measure the
bottom and the top of the
ice and get a thickness
measurement that way.
Of course, you can go there in
situ, but then how do you--you
want to get some measurement
that's kind of representative
of a large area.
It's hard to do that if you're
just walking around on the ice
with some kind of way
of drilling through.
So now there's a way to fly over
it, and use down-scanning
atmospheric acoustic waves or
electromagnetic waves to
measure sea ice thickness
as well.
So it's not a perfectly
solved problem.
But this will give
you some idea.
The scale is down
on the bottom.
It's in meters, from zero
to four meters.
And it's all over on the north
slope of Canada--north slope
of Alaska and then along the
Canadian Archipelago where you
get this deeper ice.
And that, I've made the case for
you, is not you can't grow
ice that thick
thermodynamically, by freezing
at the bottom.
Because after it gets to a
certain thickness, remember
you have to take the
heat out the top.
That's where the atmosphere
is cold.
And yet you've got to freeze
the water at the bottom.
And after a while, it becomes
too hard to get that heat to
conduct out through that
layer of sea ice.
So you can only grow sea ice
thermodynamically to this kind
of thickness.
This is a mechanical
stacking process.
And you can understand that if
you remember that across the
Arctic Ocean there is
a current called
the Transpolar Drift.
And also the Beaufort Gyre.
But that's going to be carrying
ice and pushing it up
against the north coast of
Greenland and along the
Canadian Archipelago, and then
causing that compression ridge
to form, those compression
ridges.
And that deepens the average ice
thickness to as great as
four meters, in other words,
typically a little higher than
the ceiling in this room.
Questions on that?
So here's what's been going on
the last couple of decades.
So this is the Northern
Hemisphere extent anomaly.
Remember we're learning to
understand this word anomaly,
because it's often used
in climate analysis.
What they do is take a
measurement and then subtract
off a mean value to just
emphasize the changes that
have occurred.
And this is expressed
in percent.
And zero is here.
So they've taken a year.
They've taken 1979 to the year
2000 as their reference time,
subtracted off the mean, and
then here's what's left as the
residual or as the anomaly.
So basically, in the earlier
part of the time it was--had a
positive anomaly by definition,
as it's
decreasing.
And then near the end you
get a negative anomaly.
So really the change has
been remarkable.
Overall that's about a 40% if
you count this, maybe even a
50% decrease in the area covered
by ice in September.
That's in the minimum period,
after the warming season.
There was quite a shock, and
you read about this in the
newspaper perhaps,
back in 2007.
We had this remarkable drop
in sea ice extent
in the Arctic Ocean.
Then it rebounded.
And people were saying,
well, maybe
that was just an anomaly.
Well, it was an anomaly.
But now it's come down again.
So the point is it's been
noisy all along.
But nevertheless the
trend, the downward
trend is very clear.
And what I would expect to
happen in the future, it would
decline further, but be very
noisy from year to year.
And you can extrapolate
this for yourself.
In another 20 or 30 years, it
seems like we'll have an
ice-free Arctic Ocean at the
end of the warming season.
Questions on that?
So the Southern Hemisphere,
again September.
This is the maximum,
because the minimum
doesn't make any sense.
It pulls right back pretty
much to the shores of
Antarctica.
That's pretty flat.
Or, if you looked at it very
closely, it's even increasing
ever so slightly.
And so this trend in sea ice
that we see in the Northern
Hemisphere is not found in
the Southern Hemisphere.
When we're talking about things
like global warming,
we'll come back and refer to
measurements such as this one.
But remember, this has a
somewhat different meaning,
because this is the maximum
extent of sea ice.
Whereas the other one, for the
Northern Arctic Ocean was the
minimum extent of sea ice.
Any questions on that?
And of course what's also in
the news is that now, as in
the Arctic Ocean, you get a
retreat of that minimum sea
ice in September.
You've opened up these
two long-sought
navigational routes.
For years and years in the
17th and 18th and 19th
centuries, sailors were seeking
the Northwest Passage,
trying to find a way to get
between the Atlantic and the
Pacific without going all
the way under Cape Horn.
And this is what they
were trying to do.
They never achieved it,
but now today you can.
There is a month or so in the
summer when you can take a
ship through the Canadian
Archipelago free of ice and
transport back and forth.
And in the last well, at least
in 2007, and in this year,
there's actually a northern
sea route along the north
coast of Russia that you could
use also to get back and forth
between the two oceans.
So navigation is now becoming
possible in the Arctic Ocean.
And so is things like
oil drilling.
So there's been a lot of
discussion about who's going
to lead the charge to now
developing oil resources in
the Arctic Ocean.
It's quite a change
going on up there.
So any questions on sea ice?
This was all about
frozen seawater.
Any questions on that?
Yes, Julia
STUDENT: Can you quickly review
how the wind--is it
convection?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
so the cold wind
blows over the sea.
It draws heat out of the ocean,
drops the temperature
down to zero degrees Celsius,
then below, down
to minus two Celsius.
And at that point then,
you start to freeze.
And of course, I showed you on
the first slide, you've got to
draw certain amount of heat out
for every kilogram of ice
that you make.
That's called the latent
heat of freezing.
So as you continue to draw
heat out, the temperature
doesn't drop anymore, but you
continue to build deeper and
deeper ice.
So that continues through the
month of March in the Northern
Hemisphere.
So now we turn to ice sheets,
which is generally defined as
a large plateau of ice.
And there's two things
you have to know
to understand this.
First of all, on the high
altitude parts of the ice
sheet this happens to be
Greenland, but it would be the
same for Antarctica you have
an excess of accumulation
every year.
So more snow falls during the
winter than would melt off if
indeed there's any melt at
all in the summertime.
And so year after year,
you just accumulate.
Well, that can't
go on forever.
I mean, if you accumulated a
meter of snow or 10 meters of
snow every year, by the time
you got to 10 years or 100
years or 1,000 years or 10,000
years, you would have an
enormous pile of snow.
So you have to balance that.
And what happens is that,
under its own weight, it
begins to sag and to flow.
So the snow gets compressed into
more or less solid ice.
And then that ice itself, under
high pressure conditions
with a lot of weight above it,
will begin to flow out toward
the edges of the continent.
You can simulate this next time
you've got pancakes for
breakfast. Just keep pouring
that syrup right in the middle
the pancake, and it
only get so deep.
After a while it begins
to flow off the edges.
And that's exactly
what's happening.
It's just gravity forcing that
viscous fluid toward the edges
of the pancake.
Then near the edge, there could
be some loss by melting
or direct sublimation.
Sublimation is when you go
directly from ice to vapor.
But if that's not sufficient,
then the ice will actually be
squeezed out and will
reach the ocean.
And then you'll break off those
chunks as icebergs.
But in any case, you've got to
balance the mass by having
this flow moving from the
center towards the edge.
And that's the way
ice sheets work.
That speed is not very great.
It may be only a meter per day
or even a meter per week.
Those flows can be quite slow.
But nevertheless, they balance
this annual accumulation of
snow on the high parts
of the ice sheet.
You can imagine then, if you
have this spreading going on,
there has to be some kind of a
divide, just like when we did
the river trip, we understood
that there is a divide between
water sheds.
Rain that falls on one side
goes into one river.
Rain that falls on the other
side goes into another river.
The same is true with ice.
It's called an ice divide, so
that the snowflake that falls
here will end up being squeezed
out towards the west
coast of Greenland.
A snowflake that falls there
will be squeezed out towards
the east coast and the
north and so on.
And Antarctica has
similar divides.
They're drawn here.
There's quite a number
of them, actually.
But each snowflake then will
be squeezed out ultimately
towards one part of the coast
or the other depending where
they fall relative to
these ice divides.
Any questions on that?
So when you're up on the
Greenland ice sheet,
it looks like this.
More or less continuous
sheets of deep ice.
There may be a kilometer or
more of ice beneath you.
Very deep ice.
Occasionally you may get a rocky
outcrop, a so-called
nunatak, where a mountain
ridge sticks
up through the ice.
But for the most part, there's
very deep ice, maybe a
kilometer or two of
ice beneath you.
And you don't have any sense of
that slow creeping motion,
at least not here where
it's smooth.
When the ice squeezes out to the
edge, in some places when
it reaches the sea it'll
maintain its continuity as an
ice sheet, but spread out and
begin to float over the sea.
Those are called ice shelves.
And I've shown you the dominant
ice shelves here for
Antarctica.
There's the Ross ice shelf,
the Ronne, and the Larsen.
And here's a zoom of the
Antarctic Peninsula showing
the Larsen ice sheet there.
So while that's floating out
over the ocean surface, do not
confuse it with sea ice.
It is still compacted snow.
It's fresh water in compacted
snow that's flowing out and
floating over the ocean,
being squeezed off the
continent in that way.
So it looks like this.
At least the part you can
see looks like this.
But remember, there's
another 90% or so.
Most of it is beneath the
water's surface because of
buoyancy considerations.
But that's an example
of an ice shelf, a
thick layer of ice.
Here's a ship for scale.
And basically, the ice is
attached to the land.
But eventually as it flows off
it gets water underneath.
It floats up.
Remember, ice is less dense than
water, so it floats on
the water and flows on
out as an ice shelf.
And then eventually it breaks
off to form icebergs.
Questions there?
Now, back in 19--in 2002, it
was in the news that the
Larsen ice shelf, or part
of it, had collapsed.
So here's a sequence of
satellite images.
January, 2002, February, late
February, and then March.
So here is the Larsen
ice shelf.
Remember, that's on the coast
of the Antarctic Peninsula.
I just showed that to you.
It looks like there's already
some weakening going on here.
But then over the next month or
so, most of that broke away
and floated on off
as icebergs.
There's some argument in the
scientific literature about
the significance of the
sudden loss of an
ice shelf like this.
Some would say, well, it doesn't
really mean anything,
because that ice has already
left the continent.
It's already floating
over the sea.
And it'll be replaced.
In other words, in the natural
flow of things, even in a
steady state climate, this ice
has to be replaced by new ice
coming off the land.
Others would say, no, a
catastrophic loss like this
will actually have an effect
back over the land.
And will accelerate the rate at
which glaciers are flowing
off the land onto the sea.
So that argument's a little
bit unresolved, but there
probably is some climatic
significance when you see a
sudden collapse of an
ice shelf like that.
But it can be argued one
way or the other.
Questions there?
Greenland doesn't have much
in the way of ice shelves.
There's glaciers being produced
all along both coasts.
But there's an area up here,
called the Petermann Glacier
that it might be argued has the
nature of an ice shelf.
There's the Petermann glacier.
It certainly looks like that.
It's got a broad,
flat appearance.
It's floating at this point.
I'll show you the geometry
of that here.
So here we are.
We're up in the northwest
corner of Greenland.
There's some barren land
with no ice on it.
But here comes a glacial
stream, coming down
from the ice sheet.
And at some point, it does
float out over water.
And while it is confined to a
fjord, it is floating as a
more or less continuous
ice sheet.
And so I guess even though it's
confined, it could be
called an ice shelf.
And then it will have a point
where it breaks off and
becomes icebergs
at that point.
And back just last year, in
2010, this was in the news,
that a big chunk--between July
and August of last year, a big
chunk of the Petermann
Glacier broke off.
And then this big flat, huge,
tabular iceberg drifted
northwest into the Strait of
Nares and ended up blocking
that channel for a
number of months.
We're going to right on
to icebergs then.
OK.
Here's what you need to know.
The word--the verb for what
happens when you take a
floating chunk of ice and
break it off to form an
iceberg is called calve.
So we say that icebergs are
formed from calving.
That can be either from mountain
glaciers that have
come down to the sea, or I've
just given you several
examples of where ice sheet
glaciers come down to the sea.
And then pieces can break
off to form icebergs.
Once they're floating, they
drift under the influence of
wind and ocean currents.
And don't forget to indicate
that the Coriolis force can
also play a big role
in this too.
For example, if the wind pushes
on an iceberg in that
direction, it'll move
off at right angles.
So that's because of
the Coriolis force.
They float with about 90% of
their volume under water.
We'll work out the math for
that in just a moment.
That means there's a lot
of ice underneath
that you don't see.
And if you're in a shallow part
of the ocean, they can
hit the bottom and get stuck.
So very often you'll find
icebergs that are not moving,
even though the wind is pushing
on them and the
current is pushing on them.
But they're just
stuck in place.
That would have to be because
their bottom is touching.
So they get stuck there.
They tend to melt the fastest
right around their water line.
Right where the waves splash
up against them you tend to
get this rapid melting right
around the water line.
What that will do is change the
shape of these icebergs by
carving away these grooves
around the water line.
And at some point, their shape
changes so much that their
current orientation is
no longer stable.
And then, without warning, these
things will suddenly
begin to tip.
And they'll roll to a new
orientation and then stay that
way for several weeks while
melting continues around their
new water line.
And that's rather remarkable.
If you get a chance to visit
these latitudes and if you see
a broad field of icebergs, and
if you're patient and wait a
few minutes, because there's
so many of them, you'll
probably see one or two
of them do that roll.
And that's the reason
why you don't want
to be close to them.
Because when they roll, they'll
put off a wave. And
they would swamp you if you're
in a small boat.
That'll happen suddenly,
without any warning.
So I want to show this
little calving movie.
I found it on the web.
And I want to be sure
the sound is here.
Let's see if I can
get this to work.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Oh, look at it go.
Oh my gosh.
Cindy, you have to get
a picture of that.
[INAUDIBLE]
-Wow.
Woo-hoo.
Look at all that.
Fabulous.
I'm glad we're not
next to that.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
-I can feel that.
-Oh my gosh.
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh my gosh.
[END  VIDEO  PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I don't
know what happened after that.
So that's the calving process.
So that ice has come out.
And then eventually it has
to break off pieces.
And it happens kind
of in a dramatic
fashion, as you saw there.
So from that bit of fun to the
mathematics of the situation.
So remember, Archimedes law.
We've talked about it before
in this course.
It basically says that the
buoyancy force pushing up on a
submerged obstacle--submerged
object is equal to the weight
of the fluid displaced.
So when you have an object like
this, like an iceberg,
floating in a stable
configuration, there's going
to be a balance of its own
weight with the buoyancy force
pushing it up.
So I've left the acceleration of
gravity off of both terms,
but that would be the
same in both cases.
So the weight would be the total
volume of the iceberg
times the density of ice.
That product will give you
the mass in kilograms
of the total iceberg.
And then that's going to be
balanced by a buoyancy force
pushing up, which is the volume
submerged it's only
this part multiplied
by the density
of the fluid displaced.
Well, it's displacing
seawater.
So we use the density
of seawater.
So that's the statement
of equilibrium for
this floating object.
If I simply divide through,
I can get this expression.
The ratio of the submerged part
of the iceberg to the
total is simply going to be
dividing through the ratio of
the two densities, rho ice
over rho of seawater.
And we've already used
these values before.
The density of ice is about 917
kilograms per cubic meter.
Seawater, with the salt,
is about 1,025.
Divide that out, you get 0.9.
So the point is the ratio of
this part to the total is
about 0.9, or 90%.
So that is a solid derivation of
why it is that most of the
iceberg is below sea
level there.
Any questions on that?
Now, a very interesting place on
the west coast of Greenland
is Jacobshaven.
So here is the ice sheet, the
Greenland Ice Sheet out to the
east. There's Baffin Bay to
the west. And the glacier
comes down here.
But here is indicated where
that calving front was in
1851, 1875, and back to 2003.
So it's been retreating
rather dramatically.
But I want to make something
clear to you, that even when
this retreats all the way back
here this is where the calving
is now taking place still,
this channel
is choked with ice.
It's not open water.
It's got lots of icebergs
sitting in it, some of them
making their way out.
Some of them grounded and
kind of stuck there.
But the calving front
is back there.
So again the question is, is
this a significant change?
If the channel with the fjord is
still choked with ice, does
it make any difference whether
the calving is here or the
calving is I would think it
would make a difference.
Because again, if you're calving
back here, that's
going to allow a faster flow
down from the ice sheet.
You're going to be moving more
ice from the Greenland Ice
Sheet if the calving is back
here than if it has to go all
the way up here before
it can calve off.
I was there last year and
took some pictures.
There's nothing for scale here,
but that's about 40
meters high.
And then when you think what
lies below that oh, and I'm
looking across the channels.
Through the little gap there
you can see the land on the
other side of that fjord.
But those are pretty impressive
glaciers, just the part--
icebergs, just the part
that are above water.
Here's a small ship for scale.
You can get some idea.
Has anybody seen something like
this, traveled to high
latitudes and seen something
like this?
Where were you?
STUDENT: Antarctica.
PROFESSOR: Antarctica.
Nice.
Yes.
So they look a bit different in
Antarctica, but the physics
is the same.
It depends on the shape of the
ice, how much it's crumpled as
it comes down before
it breaks off.
But basically, you've got the
same process happening in both
hemispheres.
The other reason I wanted to
show you this particular
location, Jacobshaven, is that
there's good reason to think
that it was a Jacobshaven
iceberg that sunk the Titanic.
And I want to show you
the geometry of that.
So here is Jacobshaven, on the
west coast of Greenland.
And if an iceberg breaks off
there, it'll be carried first
northward by the West
Greenland Current.
Then at some point it'll get
drawn into the Labrador
current, come down past
if it's large enough.
It will be melting as it comes
down through here.
But if it's large enough, it
will persist and possibly get
down into this area south of 50
north, and maybe even south
of 45 degrees north,
down in this area.
And at that point now, it
becomes into the great circle
route for ships between say
New York and England.
And that's what the Titanic was
doing in April of 1912.
It was making its way from
well, it started in
Southampton, England, and was
making its way to New York.
And that's where it hit
the iceberg and sunk.
So almost certainly
it came from the
west coast of Greenland.
And because Jacobshaven is known
to be the most prolific
generator of icebergs, I guess
it's a fair guess that it was
one of those Jacobshaven
icebergs that was the one that
did the deed for the Titanic.
Any questions on that?
Now we'll turn to mountain
glaciers.
And there again, a bit like the
ice sheets, you have an
accumulation zone and
an ablation zone.
So every year, full 12 months
that goes by, you've added a
bit of ice here.
And that cannot continue.
You've got to balance that
mass in some way.
And that is eventually
balanced by a flow, a
liquid-like flow down
the mountain slope
by the glacier itself.
Some of it is accomplished
by distorting the ice.
And some of it is accomplished
by just sliding the ice along
the bottom.
But in any case, it is
moving under the
influence of gravity.
And then in some cases, it makes
it all the way down to
the ocean surface.
Question, yes?
STUDENT: Can you explain
what you mean by
distorting the ice?
PROFESSOR: So if you do a viscous
experiment, if you--
let me get the lights
on for a second.
If you tilt your pancake and
pour that syrup on it, you'll
find that the syrup is not
slipping along the bottom.
It actually has a
shear within it.
Icebergs do--I'm sorry, glaciers
do some of this, but
they also slip a little
bit along the base.
So it would be more accurate
to draw it like this.
There's some internal
deformation, but there's also
some slip right at the bottom.
So it's a combination of the
two that allows it to slide
down the slope like that.
Thanks for that.
So in this case, for these two
glaciers in Alaska, they've
actually made it all the
way down to sea level.
This one easily.
This one just barely.
But any glacier that makes it
down to sea level is called a
tidewater glacier.
It makes it down, and then
partly because of the tides
but it would happen anyway
you'll get calving, and you
produce icebergs.
So a tidewater glacier will
produce icebergs that will
then float out over the sea.
You're likely to have these
in high latitudes.
Remember, you can have mountain
glaciers in low
latitudes too.
Mount Kilimanjaro in Africa,
almost exactly on the equator,
has a glacier at the top.
But it certainly doesn't
come down very far.
And it certainly does not reach
any ocean where you
would produce icebergs.
But these tidewater glaciers
do produce icebergs.
Here's an example in Alaska
of one that does
not, Stevens Glacier.
So you can see glaciers from
various parts of the mountain
chain combining and merging.
Here is the last merger
right here.
But then there's the terminus
of the glacier.
There is some melt water and
the river will carry that
water away to the sea.
The water will get to the sea,
but not the ice itself.
So this is happening
more and more.
As glaciers--as the climate
warms and glaciers retreat,
their terminus moves
further up.
But eventually that water,
of course, always
returns to the sea.
Very often you can
see the seam.
Where two glaciers come together
you have a little bit
of rock rubble.
And in some glaciers you can
see way down at their snout
you can see five or six of
these little black lines.
And if you trace them back, each
one of them originates at
a point like this.
So you can actually keep track
of all the tributaries by the
little line of rock rubble that
gets permanently put into
the glacier.
Questions there?
So again, the speed of these
things are quite slow.
They might be only a few
centimeters per day or a few
centimeters per week,
in some cases.
But what they can do is drive
a stake here, go up on the
bedrock, triangulate,
get the location.
And then come back a week or
two later and see how much
that stake has moved.
And that will at least give you
the speed of the ice at
the top of the glacier.
It won't give you everything
you need to know about the
depth all the way through,
the speed
down through the glacier.
Here's a couple of glaciers
from Norway.
The word, well, "breen" simply
means ice or glacier, and so
all the glaciers in Norway end
with the suffix "-breen." But
there's the one in Briksdal,
and there's the one in Jenn
and of course, "dal" just means
"valley" in Norwegian,
so Jennsdals glacier and
Briks valley glacier.
They're all named like that.
But these are not tidewater
glaciers.
This is not the sea.
This is a little lake at the
bottom of the glacier, a
freshwater lake.
And it has that milky appearance
to it because
underneath the glacier, where
there's a grinding process
going on, you're developing
a kind of powder from the
grinding of rock.
And that ends up in the water.
And then if you see that river,
even miles away, it'll
have that characteristic
milky appearance.
And you can say, that one
came from a glacier.
That river water came from a
glacier, because it has that
so-called glacial milk and it's
characteristic of water
that flows out from a mountain
glacier like that.
Questions there?
Here's another one.
You can see the terminus of that
and the water rushing out
from underneath in
that stream.
We are, let's see, yeah...
I guess we'll quit here
and just finish up.
There's just a little bit left
on ice, but I want to do a
good job on that.
So we'll wait until Monday
and finish that up.